les années qu'il n'a pas passé en prison
dans sa vingtaine jonathan les a conçus
mais dans l'héroïne jeu gran nous je me
réveillais sais comment je vais avoir de
l'argent comment qui je vais mettre en
danger ou qui je vais voir ce que je
pensais proche de l'overdose presque à
chaque fois que je consommais est elle
partie de moi qui disais si c'est la foi
de cette question des surdoses au québec
des chercheurs de l'université de
montréal ont documenté précisément pour
la première fois le profil des personnes
pour nous était surprenant et va à
l'encontre de l'image commune qu'on a
des gens qui décerne des souris dansent
le genre des victimes n'était pas une
surprise sept sur dix sont des hommes
mais en ce qui concerne l'âge
près des deux tiers ont plus de 40 ans
la pandémie n'arrange rien au problème
des surdoses selon ce qu urgences santé
constate sur le terrain à montréal
l'année passée en octobre il avait
administré dix fois de la naloxone
octobre de cette année quarante fois
l'administration parle de 400 %
d'augmentation
et selon jonathan qui est maintenant
intervenants pour l'organisme portage le
pire ennemi c'est l' isolement
moi je ne fais rien au montant de
consommation il n'avait pas de prendre
et me on avait comme une règle entre les
consommateurs car on n'allait jamais
lassé quelqu'un consommer ce seuil c'est
comme une règle non écrite de la rue il
a avec ça et le fait que les drogue
circule moins avec les frontières
fermées qu'elles sont davantage coupé
avec leur étude des rapports de coroners
les organismes savent maintenant que les
opioïdes ne sont qu'une composante du
cocktail mortel c'est la préssion
stratégie ça doit pas être une stratégie
pour les appuyer cette stratégie pour
les sordo ce la seule surdose de
jonathan depuis six ans
c'est celle de nicotine ici mathieu
prost radio canada montréal